We're not going to get a chance to talk
about a lot of the details on this
though it's just a great example of
reinforcement learning applied to
a difficult problem and
clever engineering tricks.
The one thing that's worth noting
is that in addition to using deep
nets which are kind of
in vogue at the moment,
they also did a couple other things in
changing the way that training happened.
That I think were really,
really important for
getting the kinds of
results that they got.
And so it wasn't just a matter of hey,
let's just use Deep Nets.
It was like Deep Nets plus
really careful training so
that you don't get these kinds
of catastrophic death spirals,
like again what my students and I have
tended to see when we try this stuff.
So this kind of doesn't
work successes story,
is not really the end of the story.
In the sense that, well, so
we assign some some reading.
I think these were reading
associated with this current lesson.
Three papers, Tesauro,
Boyan and Moore and
Sutton which kind of tell
an interesting story which is, I think,
a really nice summary of what
the state of the art is here.
So, Gerry Tesauro got
TD-Gammon to work really well.
So that's a three layer
back prop net for
learning to choose moves in
Backgammon and it worked great.
So everybody thought,
hey everything works great.
So then Boyan and Moore wrote
a paper where they showed that
there's some very simple examples
where things ought to work well but
they need not,
they can actually work extremely poorly.
Using this general approach
of substituting in
a function approximator for a Q
function can lead to terrible results.
So, it need not work.
Then Sutton had a reply to that where
he published a paper that said, yeah,
but you can,
you can do it if you do it right.
So, he actually replicated
the same results that Boyan and
Moore showed, not working and showed
that if you change the way the training
happens you can get those
particular things to work, but
this really is just, the argument is it
need not work, but it need not not work.
[LAUGH] Which is not really
a very strong kind of guarantee.
It's not like it has to work or
it has to not work.
So this is kind of where we are now
in terms of our understanding.
>> So
what's the Pollack thing at the bottom?
>> Pollack?
Sorry, so yes.
I just wanted to point out that
why did backgammon work so well?
It might not have just been the fact
that it was reinforcement learning,
it might have been, well backgammon is
kind of a good thing to learn this way.
So, Jordan Pollack had a paper where he
showed that genetic algorithms can also
do particularly well in
backgammon in particular.
So, it might not have been
that Jerry Tesauro discovered
that TD is really great,
he might have discovered that backgammon
is really great as a test bed for TD.
>> Yeah, I remember that.
In fact the argument that Jordan
made was that because it's so
random it forces you to do
all kinds of exploration and
keep you from falling
into certain traps.
That made generalization powerful and
in fact if we compared to Isabelle's
master thesis work on something that you
thought was simpler, like tic tac toe.
It actually doesn't do terribly well on
tic tac toe, and that's because it's so
deterministic there's huge
chunks of the state space,
you kind of never see even when you're
trying to do this generalization.
>> Yeah.
Okay.
And I would summarize that by saying
that nearby states in tic tac toe don't
necessarily have nearby values.
You just move one x to
a different place on the grid.
And the whole gameplay
is very very different.
Backgammon, because it has such
a tremendously influential random
component.
If you move one piece,
it can change things but
it's not going to change
things you know night and day,
it's going to change things gradually
and so that kind of gradualness means
that function approximation is probably
going to, well could at least work out.
>> Maybe,
it's certainly a good argument.